nevada is full of military history
around world war ii you could see the
atomic bomb tests you could feel the
jets soaring by
but some sacrifices have been lost in
time one town decided though it was time
to remember
and what happened down there in
abandoned city
in their own way they're monuments two
enormous empty airplane hangars
towering as they have a few miles east
of tonopah for nearly 80 years
today crows call the hangers home back
then it was soldiers
at the tonepaw army airfield up to six
to seven
thousand people that went through here
as officers
alan metcher leads the central nevada
museum he's researched the airfield's
short history for more than
30 years from 1942 until the end of
world war ii
this was one of the army's largest
flight training sites
five thousand square miles thousands of
soldiers and their families
b-39s and b-24s their crews flew here
just before being sent to battle
if they were lucky to survive fatal
crashes there had there was at least 35
or 40.
bomber crews called the tonopah army
airfield jinxed
the high altitude made it extremely hard
to fly
by metcher's count at least 130 airmen
lost their lives while training for
combat
crash sites can be found around the
desert even today
and then a week after vijay day
they started shipping out troops and
aircraft and the whole nine yards
in a flash the tonopah base was gone
only these hollow buildings remain
they died heroes is in our eyes they
died as heroes
for tronopod native bob prichetti i get
choked up
there's nothing hollow about the
airfield's legacy
and the men who died it gets a lot more
so yeah
he is one of several volunteers to
create this new
memorial it sits right off us-95 in the
center of tonopah
this is the first proper recognition of
the soldiers who lost their lives
long overdue honoring these men a
dedication is planned for memorial day
weekend each one of those young men that
died here
sacrificed their life they wanted to get
their training done with
and get over there to europe or the
pacific or where they were needed
and when that were now the story can go
beyond the empty hangers and abandoned
wreckage
every one of these guys have a story
it's where it should be
or everyone can remember so many of us
knew it
this last forever now a memorial
dedication
up in tonopah was supposed to happen
last year as you see the memorial is
done
that ceremony was postponed by the
pandemic but they're going to have it
this year instead
for more on the history of the tonopah
army airfield we're going to have a link
up at 8newsnow.com it's a very
interesting history
well worth researching and head up to
tone upon learn more about it yourself
too